dude did you see these two did you see
this is how just weird the world is
getting stop is like did you see the two
there was I think Mullins was the guy's
name in the
um the
senator what was this this was I think
this was yesterday or two days ago
Republican senator Mark Wayne Mullen
challenged Teamsters president Shawn
O'Brien to fight during a senate hearing
rising from a seat before the committee
chair stepped in to diffuse a
conversation this is pretty interesting
the senator
challenge him to a fight yeah it's just
crazy that like this is where we're at I
know
dude yeah let's play it now let's talk
about Mr O'Brien himself his behavior as
everybody knows and this here and the
last time him and I kind of had a back
and forth but after you left here you
got pretty excited about the keyboard in
fact
you tweeted at me one two three 4 Oh
Come five times and let me read what the
last one said um it said quit the tough
guy Act in these Senate hearings you
know where to find me any place anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place no it's not [__] you're in the
[__]
Senate okay that's fine perfect you want
to do it now I'd love to do it right
now stand up bu oh hold stop it your
solutionary no no sit
down you know you're a United States
Senator okay get his ass Bernie can I
respond hold it get his ass Bernie this
is a hearing God knows the American
people have enough at contempt the
Congress let's not don't like thugs and
buies I don't like you cuz you just
described yourself hold it you have the
mic you have time all right your
statement then let's do this because I
did challenge you and I accepted your
challenge and you went quiet no I didn't
go quiet I was you challenged me to a
cage match acting like a 12-year-old
School excuse me hold it no excuse me I
have I will say I will say exactly mull
I have the mic you have questions on any
economic issues anything go for it we're
not here to talk about physical abuse
you that's good man that's [__] crazy
meanwhile that guy has two U valde moms
sitting behind him like so sad about
what happened to their kids and that's
what they're doing dude that's insane
the S talking about being you're [__]
made no you're [__] made yeah and he's
three and0 Mark Wayne what he fighting
huh I guar oh yeah MMA he play a unar
you think he had the under giant with
the one yeah with the one shoulder he's
out of Westville Oklahoma wow so he was
maybe Semi-Pro interesting um did he
have a nickname though that would be his
best does it have
his the senator what if his nickname was
the Senator Mark big government I like
that big government Mark you have two
names you oh he beat Clinton bonds oh
Clinton bonds he beat him twice he
fought Bobby Kelly he fought
dude stop [__] hitting me dude what
the
[__] he
L that's awesome but it's just that's
weird man where it's getting now is
that that's how we're going to raise
money for the for the for their County
or whatever for their state they're
going to do an only they're going to do
a fight versus an only fans model and
that's where the funding is going to
it's like the government is dead man
it's like that's what happens when you
don't get money when it's so clear that
these [__] are bought and paid
for that you don't respect them anymore
and so then it becomes not who do I
trust to like take care of my district
but who's cool and it becomes a [__]
weird popularity contest and you get a
guy who'll probably be like I'm not a
[__] I challenge some [__] dork to a
fight and then some [__] morons will
be like that's my [__] guy or like
what's your face jacking off that guy of
Beetle Juice
like that was the coolest thing she's
ever done Lauren bber she jacked she
over the pants jacked her date first
date I don't agree with her politics but
I do agree with her stance as a date
yeah that's that's her date etiquette is
awesome yeah especially in a movie theat
and it was a packed movie theater I
remember seeing that I was like wow
there's other people right there and
it's like it's the Trump effect of like
yeah the guy's entertaining yeah the
guy's [__] entertaining they I feel
I'm at the point with Biden just they
it's not feels like they shouldn't do
this to an old person oh dude it's fully
elder abuse that's what I feel like yes
yes and it feels like it's almost like
they're trying to create Stockholm
syndrome within us that we think it's
crazy like like if that were my dad or
grandpa I would be like hey don't do
this look how sad he
looks holy [__] he looks so [__] sad
dude the other day one that first of all
that looks like a guy wearing a Joe
Biden mask
somebody get that [__] his
dosage of [__] super Aderall what the
[__] dude they do I do not want to see
him in public unless they've got him
dosed with like whatever [__] you
know growth hormone whatever dude he is
how good how good do you whatever he's
they give him must feel awesome ERS or
peptides you think whatever it is dude
some kind of [__] we don't even know
about but yeah the other day he answer
there was some question you see that
video he answered Clarissa Explains It
All with his answer holy [__] that was
when I was a child
that's awesome dude that's 20 years ago
but yeah he just smelled a kid this
morning and they he's like how old are
you there's a new video and he he's like
are you 17 and her brother goes she's
sick sorry old habits die hard he's just
clicking he's got the kind of dementia
where he's like now he's acting like he
did in his 40s and now was when he's
riding that Am track down to Delaware
cute woman sits next to him on the on
the [__] uh heading honey yeah yeah
you're seven right yeah yeah he knows
the age of consent of all the states the
Amtrak passes goes New York Jersey East
Town oh your six your birthday is SE
September 10th hey stop the train right
here
conductor stop it for 12 minutes hey
let's slow down in Delaware you know I'm
trying to meet a
girl he knows the safe havens the
16-year-old say at the age of oh you
know he was up hey hey right hey let me
know before we reach the
bomic you know I got to I got to
telegram a girl charger res bid and ask
six-year-old girl if she's 17 dude is
this what is this guy want to be a
comedian it's funny though to call him
creepy it's like all right guys he's
clearly losing his mind that's what I
don't like let's get you know yeah I
don't have I have the faculties to be a
pedophile anymore right that's the
unfair part of it yeah it's like yeah
cut down in his prime now that he's
finally now that he's finally got all
the power in the world he's two SE now
to be a
pedophile
it's heartbreaking of those pedophiles
dude it's like the [__] uh the um uh
[__] what's the the old the old sci-fi
uh oh why not you're talking about uh
Twilight Zone Black Mirror top Twilight
Z yes Twilight Zone where the guy has
all the time in the world and his
glasses break and he can't read anymore
he's like but there was time now that's
Biden now he's like but I'm the
president now I could go to Epstein's
Island yeah it's like like no it's over
sorry Joey it's the rides are shut down
yeah just a scile Joe Biden sadly
walking through an empty Epstein's
Island like what now that I get in it's
[__] done that was the ticket booth
right there he's just seeing a plaque
with just like [__] Bill Clinton
smiling
yeah that's why I want a stuffed four
14-year-old that's why I want a gold
fish
that's what we called him it was a
Chinese
boy if you do the [__] if you do the
[__] ski
ball they have that those disc toss but
it's on a Chinese boy's penis you got to
get it
on high
difficulty let's just say high
difficulty wow you're like man there's
no way to get this on there huh you're
like complaining to the guy I saw Bill
do it he did he had a whole [__] I
saw Steven Hawking build a robot that
could do
it yeah they're like Dice Clay landed a
smoke ring on
it Trump claimed it was fixed
yeah I could do
it it's true that it's like these op
none of these options are good where
it's like you see um like on polling
like the little stuff that I pay
attention to it's like when you ask
people generic generic Democrat versus
Trump generic Democrat wins and you ask
them generic Republican versus Biden
generic Republican wins it's like they
just don't want these guys nobody wants
these guys and it's like Democrats have
nobody they have no like KLA harff has
no sauce whatsoever we're not even
making a plan though that's what that's
the part I don't understand like what
could their strategy be they can't have
Joe Biden run again I don't think it's
because it's just not going to be to me
it just gets to the point where it's
like that's the part that's me makes me
sad it's like can we stop doing this to
this guy like it's just not fair let him
eat some ice cream right bring in Kamal
bring somebody else in his stead right
now that at least is a somebody who's
viable right and for all intents and
purposes we should consider him dead
like he's not he is technically
breathing but like for all intents and
purposes the guy's got to you know you
like let him [__] retire let him hang
out retire dude he's had a whole nice
career of being a [__] you know one
of the most lucky guys of all time but I
don't know dude but his son died you
know yeah his son died in um he was in a
union fire or he was doing something he
was in the merchant marines he was on
the top of kilamanjaro and his son
passed away fell into a black school
district and died at the hands of uh
Narcan and local I believe that's what
it was either that or brain cancer I
can't tell I would think it was that
though he he might have I think he
drowned at the Autobon
zoo somewhere outside of cincin
[Laughter]
when Joe burrow threw him to a pass over
the middle yeah him out the dry Al
Wilson hit
him you hate to see that man God I
remember it like it was yester year I
remember it like it was
tomorrow but
talk oh yeah this dude this this is just
exactly where we are again as a society
George George Santos M they said he
spent 400,000 on only fans again of his
campaign fun I got to say respect cuz
this guy's a [__] idiot and he's like
like that's the thing this guy's a crook
right yeah and he re
realistically like was like well a way
to be a CR a sick way to be a crook is
to be a or representative and he's just
[__] killing it dude yeah this
happened more and more he spent a
honeymoon in
Vegas um he did a Hampton's holidays
being a chubby guy with botox is awesome
Hampton in huh that's not very expensive
no no the Hampton in [__] uh Long
Island oh [__] that dude I like Hampton
they redid them about 12 years ago the
Hampton ends they're great you're a
Hampton in guy I love them elevators are
all the same they have like a little
nice positive thing on it with like a
black kid on a rope swing or like a
white kid like getting a lemonade from
his grandma yes yes yes I was always a
holiday and express man really when it
came to the lower levels I I haven't
been to I not a Hampton in guy my top
spender she put up well here's his
problem he also put George Santos as his
screen name wait what the [__] that's a
girl right that was her but her top
spender she's saying she's an only fans
model but he's gay Santos is gay is he
yeah well he spent
$435,000 attempting to not be gay what
the [__] go to this girl's is that a is
she trans or something or is she does
she Peg guys yeah let's see if she's
transed up or maybe she [__] guys no
wow I mean if she's trans I'm sucking
that thing no problem if she's Str dude
uh Red Rover Red Rover I'll be right uh
oh I might have to I'll be right over
wow what's her name I mean she seems
like she has she might be trans which
again no problems here Su ass sex huh
why don't we scroll down just a little
bit and George Santos was looking at her
I thought that guy was gay as hell yeah
he might not be gay anymore I think for
$435,000 you can make it out of
anything
you know yeah that's true where I'm from
anyway that's a nice no that's a nice
chunk yeah you know that's a nice chunk
absolutely you can stuff the condoms
full of money and just to keep your dick
hard that way in a
woman worst case scenario doesn't Santos
also have like a hot also scammer sister
I think I saw somebody tweet about that
well a lot of people are just making it
to Pol it's politics now but it's like
they're well it's it's funny because you
don't want lifelong politicians it feels
like cuz the system is so dirty but then
it's also like you you get these like
just fly by night kind of people like
fedman right um who I'm not saying is
bad or good but he's just you know so
long as he shows up like he's you know
like it's a off day or whatever yeah
he's got his [__] uh sweat shorts on
me and him dress way too similar oh
that's a good point although he's not
this dripped out but you know oh my on
my on my travel days no if you're
dripping he's he he's a leak yeah it's
like he like Champion Athletics yes yes
yes you know which a lot I respect it
it's comfortable yeah I know dude it's
it's tough not to be like like almost
like nihilistic where the shit's just
not going to get better where you're
like it just feels like they're G to
they're going to suck people dry so much
and I just don't see any representation
of like what a lot of I mean it would
have to be like a a youth movement I
think but right of of like young people
just having enough of the [__] and like
cuz old people are just going to stay
conservative that's how it goes
traditionally and I just think like I
don't know man you just got to [__] has
to get shaken up and we just need just
basic [__] I mean you saw obviously I
was a big Bernie guy and you there was a
big outpouring of like like Trump and
Bernie it's not a it's not a coincidence
that two kind of outside different
things really registered with people I
wish they have ran together yeah I
really do because I think then you have
where the two if one of gets Vice one of
them gets president they have to compete
they have to work really work together
instead of just working with some guy
you picked you have to work with the
other side guys I know what you mean but
there's no way like those guys were so
aart on so much [__] but I know what you
mean like a as a as a person an American
would it in like oh that this is what I
need